Gabriel where'd you grow up where you
from from Houston Texas Houston and tell
me about your family you grew up with
both of your parents well my parents are
incarcerated
you know dad had three life sentences
mom kept getting locked up for
prostitution so my grandma and
grandfather raised me praise me how was
your childhood
my dad was good my child was good it was
kind of took us past a real
old-fashioned we didn't get to do
everything everybody else did
it's like school church and home no boy
now you're nothing you say maybe being
with your grandparents might better move
than being with your real parents
yeah just say you know things that we
didn't get to do like I'm Wow you know
when I get to start knowing time you
know you know I'm kind of rebellious oh
yeah I'm gonna sneak out the window and
you wouldn't let us do anything so what
were your parents in prison for my dad
was um yeah I think I think he a
capital-murder something like that so he
got three life sentences what my mom mom
kept getting busted with cocaine and
prostitution multiple prostitution
charges so after you left your
grandparents I got kicked out at 15
because I got pregnant and I had the
baby yeah yeah I thought the man was in
love with me but he's 17 years old so of
course he didn't show to the hospital
how old was he he was deafening wickety
you know 70 mm-hmm and you were 15
mm-hmm I thought that you know we were
gonna make it work but that was a lot I
have seven now I've said
his home well did you raise your kids I
raised three three of the UM seven um
most my kids are biracial so my oldest
daughter said that you know he was too
friendly with her down there we went
through all this on litigations and I
lost all my kids I'm also my mind soon
cuz I really don't know what I really
miss with that I'm with them 24/7 but I
believe him
it's you my daughter so kind of like a
rock and a hard place sir so where are
your kids now they're in Texas they're
all in the system
yeah and you how old are you 28 you're
28 you've been out here in skid row for
hold on five months I see your brand-new
you came straight from Texas or hmm so
you're fairly new to LA yeah welcome to
the worst part of the way Bailey of the
beef yeah and where you staying now I
feel out of post you know I'm same where
I came from staying you know SRO
sometimes you know sometimes I wherever
you can find a place to sleep
build me a cardboard house keep from
getting any sense there's only one door
I make another one easily but anyways
yep getting into attendance dangerous
sometimes yeah
yes dangerous and then what's what's
your drug okay correct correct okay what
did you start with that 22 wit my mom
we're in the closet
and then what are you doing for money
now
anything I can you didn't date a guy yes
yeah have you been arrested out here no
you haven't
and we're doing that in Texas as well
yeah yeah
and that that gets dangerous at times
right yes it's really dangerous but it's
like you know the last couple of weeks
down here you know I had me three four
dollars trying to get me something in at
this promotion on me chemo and then I go
yeah come on little mama you know help
me out they might give me like double
what I paid for if not triple and I
turned my back to leave and all of a
sudden like help me and stuff here
ours are no good it's really dangerous
you might not make it out but if you
fast like a cat like me you can climb
trees and fences I'm good for you down
that's what that is yeah what do you
think your chances are of getting off
the street and getting clean from from
crack and stuff I think I have a 50/50
chance I'm really headstrong I know I'm
better than this it's just like I can't
get away from the thrill and now I
really need some milk which is I don't
think I could do it by myself what do
you what do you think would help you me
um mental he'll taught me something uh
rehabilitation maybe even getting going
to jail might save my life I don't know
going to jail seems to be the key for a
lot of people that just can't do it on
their own it's just a way now it's just
a way out for me yeah the trick is just
to stay clean after you get out of jail
yeah he's getting expedite at home
something you didn't getting back to
Texas would help you I think it would
they one sort of a problem if I'm not
there mentally so I go anywhere yeah
mine ain't there you know it gonna do me
no good is is is living the street life
different in Houston it is out here
mhm how's it different cuz I can't walk
the streets after I live in a clock
there guaranteed I probably wouldn't
make it back why is that
okay I mean I'm the officer I'm sorry
damn y'all didn't put a bullet in my
hair faster there than they will lose it
dangerous though yes getting all to the
corner store they do it yes they really
gangbang hard there it's no chance I'd
make it you have you've had friends busy
rocks
I know a lot of people that I knew
they're not here no more they are gonna
mean you talking with any of your family
at all
no nobody until we faint mom and dad are
gone or their store on I don't know
about my dad I'm kind of scared to know
who he is and everything ain't got in
touch with him my mom I talked to her
yesterday night and everything I told I
need a birth certificate for my gr still
pending
I need my ID for my Social Security
check again when you were a kid did you
have dreams of a different life yeah I
had dreams of family but I know I know
now that's just a fairy tale
I make like what it is starting on my
greatest adversary I know that no just a
piece of hope to hold on to I think I
can make it how do you think living in
the street life is has changed you
you've been doing it through I think I
think it's built up a resilient a brick
wall I don't trust nothing nobody tell
me especially if they got that thing so
they might like me broken promises none
of that it's like all out the window
when I see them doing what I'm doing
because they ain't bout nothing your
friends
I have associates can't really trust
anyone
yeah all right John well thank you so
much for talking to me and good luck out
there thank you I hope you figure out a
way out of it off the street I
appreciate that
thanks for coming back
welcome you won a few you never judge me
you treat me like I'm human
humane I really love that too I really
do I had to get that off my chest you
listen to me you did all right Kenny
well thank you for coming in and talking
you